hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the five nights at
candy's 3 demo now the developer was
trying to get the full game out before
the end of the year but unfortunately it
looks like there was a delay but now I
get to play the demo
I've played both five nights at candy's
one and two so I'm kind of excited to be
able to play this one because it has not
been a disappointment it's been a pretty
good one but again this is just a demo
look around with a mouse you can look to
the sides and also up and down look down
and two buttons will appear the blue
button turns you to the tape player the
red button lets you look underneath the
bed okay if the monster attacks hold the
flashlight in the monsters eyes until it
goes way if the monster goes into your
bed find out which side of bed is hiding
under then while not looking under the
bed look in the north of direction of
the bedroom to lure the monster to peek
out from under the bad wood here at peek
it out turn to the other side of the bed
I don't know what the hell you're
talking about
playing the music tape in the tape
player makes the night go much faster it
is possible to survive the night without
using that I don't know I'm not gonna oh
god oh I'm not gonna win this oh I'm not
gonna win this oh I'm not gonna win this
oh hi hi hello is that me back when I
had black hair oh boy oh oh oh god oh no
the room is so big
oh god no la la la la oh my god I don't
like this at all okay is he here oh [ __ ]
hey I saw that I saw all of that
you bring none of that in my house yeah
[ __ ] why is this my Eyes's goddamn room
so freaking big it's so big ok so I
noticed the tape player [ __ ] stop I
don't know what you are yet calm down oh
boy
I am I might be in a spot of bother oh
boy that's no good
that's not good what was that hi hello
what hi and where and what I hear noises
but I see nothing oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
well that's not good
piggies under the bed nope not under the
bed oh boy
I'm dead I'm dead I did oh god I'm dead
oh God why hello I saw something but I
still haven't seen you oh god I gotta I
gotta like play the tape again I guess
rewind
give it it oh okay yeah oh boy
well that's not good oh okay yeah look
into the flashlight does that bother you
are you bothered by that I think I
remember you whoa that's not good
Oh am i dead I might be dead I might to
be very dead oh hi hello hi
okay okay all about okay bye okay all
right cool great good good having your
visit oh it's love when company comes
over now if you could go [ __ ] yourself
and never come back that'd be great -
all right cool oh boy oh boy I'm I'm
boned I'm boned okay anyway let's rewind
that
[Music]
and just take this calmly one step at a
time until we die that's not good that's
not a good sign that's a bad sign that's
one of them bad eyes [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop that same place being [ __ ]
having mouth shaking piece of ass bitin
dick and tree - [ __ ] off and [ __ ] you
and go down and die god damn it well
he's under my bed that's nice okay we're
yet buddy boo where you at where you at
buddy boo [ __ ] god damn it I don't
know how to beat you thank you
okay well game over I died that's great
here I go again having to try one more
time
[ __ ] fantastic okay so that is
difficult that is very difficult that's
very difficult okay oh I don't know how
to beat that but I'll try again
oh I'll try again oh I get it this is
from the perspective of the monster
looking in on the room ah yeah death
okay thank you it's gonna play that make
the night go much faster sure wish I
could turn my head faster that'd be of
great help to everybody involved here
hahahahaha okay come on come on come on
to me I'm here come on to me bro I'm
ready
ah oh it's me it's me oh I did not
notice that oh they're so cool I mean
the game I have red hair I don't have
that anymore
hahaha [ __ ] my [ __ ] god damn it why
are you there
don't do that alright so I guess I guess
after this phase he's got I got a I got
a look on
bed which doesn't seem like a good idea
I want to stress that fact here we go
okay are you're on that side so I can
look over here then look back Oh quickly
quickly quickly
okay that's not good okay
your allotted Dottie Dottie da looking
over there rock all right so that's
[ __ ] impossible so I guess I can't
look over as far but that is a thing all
right I'm gonna give it another go but
give it like at least two more goes
before I give up on this remember this
is just a demo this isn't the full game
the full game is going to be released at
some point in the future very soon
hopefully in the next month but this is
just demo don't know if I can beat it
don't know how to play Oh heard that
heard that heard that heard that ok
heard that heard something oh hey okay
all right I see you okay I see you so
there's like I don't know what they mean
by a lot faster but night is definitely
not going a lot faster with the music
[ __ ] okay is somewhere okay so it's
oh did I I did I didn't notice but
apparently I saw him so let me just get
this I'll rewind and okay all right okay
all right okay all right okie dokie okie
dokie you whine and get back up quickly
quickly quickly quickly okay I I really
don't know if that's helping at all it
seems like the night is still very very
long like very very long night here so I
don't know what this is doing to help me
but I think
Hey so I'm just gonna do it anyway cuz
I'm apparently I'm asleep
according to somebody for that [ __ ]
they [ __ ] no no no no no no no no stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop no no
no I'm gonna beat you
ah you did you beat me ha oh that's very
dumb [ __ ] he's under the bed so I just
got a peek under see what side I think
he's on the right I guess off [ __ ] I
didn't see [ __ ] god ok he's on the right
ok so I just gotta look over here hello
looking away looking back looking back
looking what I [ __ ] did it
I did the thing it said god damnit one
more try one more try if the monster
attacks will the flash light on the
monsters eye until it goes away if if
monster goes into your bed well it's
almost impossible to make him go away
find out what side of the bed he's
hiding under then while not looking
under the bed look in the direct other
direction of bedroom to lure him to peek
out and hear it peeking out turn to the
other side of the bedroom then strike
with your flashlight oh ok I guess when
you hear it peeing out alright one more
go one more try one more try I got this
maybe not I don't got this I probably I
definitely don't got this i 100% don't
got this are you going where you going
Regan what you doing what you do would
you I see you gonna play my tape gonna
play my fun tape it's a fun tape full of
fun times
don't forgot some [ __ ] yous in there
it's my fun [ __ ] tape that's bad for a I
don't have a fun [ __ ] tape that's dad's
just bad I bet a band I'm bailing out of
this joke I'm failing nope back flipping
out of this joke there's not good joke
table I should shut up I shut up is what
I should do I'm not showing up though
that's not what I'm doing
I'm still talking actually surprising
them so Dargan whoa whoa hello hey
[ __ ] stop no gonna win this time
we're gonna lose you lose you lose but
come on okay fine all right we're yet
whoa okay you're on that side huh so I'm
just gonna oh god yeah hahaha okay all
right I get it I get it now
buh-bye oh boy okay fine [ __ ] you heard
that there yeah yeah I heard you yeah I
heard you I'm gonna play my tape now cuz
apparently still only two I am [ __ ]
nights take forever
yeah I'm halfway through you go [ __ ]
yourself
go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself are
you going well I see you I saw that try
to hide my closet down there are Kelly
rat sex rat Kelly that's a bad joke
again god damn it stop doing that it's a
high-stress situation I can't make good
jokes hey yep you're going away that's
what you're gonna be doing you're not
gonna go anywhere so I kind of got the
strategy down as soon as you hear the
steps you got to go to one extreme
whatever extreme you're closest to and
then you got to hit that and immediately
go back and he'll be in the other one
whoa what the [ __ ] was that
don't do surprises I am just explaining
the stratagems here [ __ ] do not do
that I am in a controlled environment
you're not gonna [ __ ] with me [ __ ]
stop that where are you [ __ ] stop at
goddamnit I'm gonna win you can lose
who's gonna lose you're gonna lose
you're gonna lose you're gonna lose
you're gonna lose you lose you lose
[ __ ] goddamn it okay here we go don't
don't do me if you kill me I will [ __ ]
you punk out vodka goodbye freak oh okay
so I'm not even gonna bother rewinding
it again after this because I'm pretty
sure there's not enough time oh [ __ ]
there yeah Oh got ya got ya got ya
okay alright you're not even gonna
bother rewinding and not even gonna
bother not even gonna bother
maybe I should bother I should probably
bother boy I'm gonna bother I'm gonna
bother rewinding it be kind rewind you
know it's always good it's good it's
good habit have oh jeez [ __ ] what hi
okay thanks for announcing it Juche I
mean you're number yay I did it that was
as hard as 20 mode ha no it was not but
okay it was still pretty good
I liked it end of the demo see you soon
okay yes with your ugly ass Frankenstein
tail you are a lovely person and I love
you a lot so anyway it's actually good
to see this because it's been a long
time since I played five nights at
candy's one or two I played them at the
beginning of last year so this is the
beginning of this year now so it's kind
of nice to see it come around and with
an interesting mechanic
I mean having the double wide room is
kind of disconcerting and I like that
but there's some cool stuff that can be
done with this I just think there might
need to be a few more characters I'm
hoping they're gonna be or maybe it's
gonna be a spring strap style thing but
we'll see what happens when the full
game gets released so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know if you want a full playthrough that
when it comes out and as whoa hang on a
second I see those buttons hey if you
look behind I'm gonna brighten this
impose but I think I see something
there's
but I see that and I see you so thank
you again everybody and let me know down
in the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]